all right there's a free worksheet I'll
have a link to that in the description
below if you want to work through these
on your own and then we're gonna go
through them together here in this video
I'm also going to be explaining how to
decide what type of factoring technique
you're going to want to use in each
situation and then we're going to factor
completely meaning sometimes we have to
factor further and further and further
until it's completely factored as we go
through this video the promised way to
get more challenging let's dive into the
first problem we've got 8x squared plus
6x the first thing you want to do in
this decision tree here is you want to
ask yourself is there a greatest common
factor that's the most important thing
in factoring you always want to do that
first ask yourself is there something I
can divide out of all the terms and
remember the terms are separated by plus
or minus when I look at this here I can
see that these both of these terms you
could divide out a 2 ok so they're due
by 2 you can also divide out 1x the
others x squared that's like x times X
here you just have 1x so the most we can
divide out would be like a 2x so what
we're gonna do is we put that 2x in
front of the parenthesis and you can see
her free divide 8 divided by 2 is 4x
squared divided by X is just going to be
1 X 6 divided by 2 is 3 and here the x's
cancel so we're just left with 4x plus 3
the nice thing about factoring is you
can always check your answer you just
take that 2x distribute it back into the
parentheses and you're gonna get back
that original polynomial and you've got
it now with faster you'll always want to
ask yourself can I factor more you know
could I take this 4x plus 3 and break it
down further well in this case this is
as far as we can go so that's it so
number 2 let's look at this one we've
got x squared minus X minus 12
how would you factor that one well again
if we go to our decision tree we see
that we have three terms okay and you
can see there's not a greatest common
factor we always want to check for that
first but we've got three terms which
means that okay we have to look is it's
a trinomial is the leading coefficient
here one or is it not one well in this
case you can see the leading coefficient
is just one so we can jump right into
the factoring this is an easy way to do
it you just have to ask yourself what
two numbers multiply to negative 12 but
they have to add to that middle
coefficient negative 1 well you can see
that's going to be negative
or in positive three they multiply to
negative 12 about negative four plus
three add to negative one you want to
look to see if you can factor further
but in this case that's as far as we can
go and you've got it let's go to number
three we've got four x squared minus 25
okay first step remember you always want
to check your greatest common factor
there's nothing we can divide out of
both of these terms let's see how many
terms do we have we have two three or
four we've got two terms okay because
you can see again the terms are
separated by plus or minus and so that
means if we have two terms we want to
check is it a difference of two perfect
squares or is it a sum of two cubes or a
difference of two cubes well when you
look at this we can see that 4x squared
is a perfect square because 2x times 2x
and we know that 25 is a perfect square
we know that's 5 times 5 and when we
factor a difference of two squares we
have a sum and difference pattern when
you're adding when you're subtracting so
this is 2x plus 5 and 2x minus 5
notice the 10x and the negative 10x they
cancel that's why we don't have a middle
term we just have like a first in the
last term so this one was a difference
of two squares okay again remember
there's a link to a free worksheet with
all these 100 examples are gonna be
going through go ahead and print that
out and follow along or do them on your
own and then check your answers again
here but number 4 we've got 8 X cubed
minus 27 so first up what do you think
is there a greatest common factor well
it doesn't look like there is now how
many terms are there are there two three
or four terms there's two terms we want
to decide if it's a difference of two
squares or a sum or difference of two
cubes here this is actually going to be
a difference of two cubes 8x cubed is
really like 2x times 2x times 2x and 27
is really like 3 times 3 times 3 so you
can see we have a difference of two
cubes and our formula here a and B a is
going to be 2x B is going to be 3 so
we've got 2 X minus 3 we've got 2 x
squared which is 4 x squared we've got a
B which is going to be 6 X and we have B
Square which is a negative 3 times
negative 3 which is positive 9 now one
thing that's too
sometimes utilize when they're doing the
sum and difference of two cubes is this
acronym soap and it stands for same
opposite always positive meaning that if
you're adding right like so you're
adding you would add if you're
subtracting you would subtract okay and
then so that's the same right then it's
the opposite meaning if you added here
you're going to subtract here if you
subtract here you're going to add here
so the second one it's going to be the
opposite sign right and then the last
one ap is always going to be positive so
that was just going to be a positive
nine so we'll do some more sum and
difference of two cubes I've got
examples of all these different types of
factoring I'll put links in the
description below if you want to focus
in on a particular type but this is just
designed to go through all the different
types at once
in a random order to help you practice
your factoring skills so let's go to
number five we've got 6x squared plus 7x
minus five so first step greatest common
factor doesn't look like there's a
greatest common factor how many terms
two three or four looks like three terms
is the leading coefficient one no okay
leading coefficient is not 1 so we're
gonna use you to the AC method the box
method trial and error method etc let's
do the box method so what we're going to
do is we're gonna say a times C ok 6
times negative 5 is negative 30 what two
numbers multiply to negative 30 but they
have to add to 7 so what do you think
that would be multiplies to negative 30
adds to 7 well it looks like that's
going to be 10 and negative 3 so what we
do when we do the Box method is we draw
a box like this we put the first term in
the first box we put the last term here
in the last box and then the 10 and the
negative 3 I'm going to write this as
10x and negative 3x that adds up to the
middle term which is 7x okay
then what you do is you look at these
rows okay horizontally and you ask
yourself what can i factor out on both
of these two terms 6x squared + 10 X
well we can factor out a 2x and if I do
that I'm going to be left with 3x + 5
okay because 5 times 2x is 10x and what
can i factor out on both of these it
looks like we can only factor out a
negative 1 and so you can see 3x times
now
negative 3x negative 1 times 5 is
negative 5 and now we've got it factored
it's just gonna be 2x minus 1 times 3x
plus 5 and that's your factored form
let's go to number 6 now here we've got
four terms okay is there a greatest
common factor no so we're gonna check to
see if it's factoring by grouping when
there's four terms so what we do is we
group those first two terms together we
group those last two terms together and
just remember that these are all added
they're not multiplied yet we're gonna
factor out the greatest common factor
which is 3x squared so that's gonna give
us X minus 1 here we're gonna factor out
the greatest common factor which is a 2
and we're left with X minus 1 now notice
how there's an X minus 1 in both these
groups if we factor out that X minus 1
from this group we'd be left with 3x
squared if we factor out the X minus 1
from this group we'd be left with 2 and
then you can see if you were to
distribute the X minus 1 back in you
would get back the original polynomial
again you with factoring completely you
always want to see if you can factor
further but in this case this is as far
as we can go that's your final result
there okay so for number seven what do
you think for this one is there a
greatest common factor no is there three
terms four terms or two terms looks like
there's three terms the leading
coefficient is not one you can see it's
a four okay so we could use the AC or
box method or the trial and error method
but there's another technique and you
might recognize this this is called a
perfect square trinomial and the way you
would look at this is you would say okay
this is a perfect square to see x - c is
for c squared this is a perfect square
five times five is 25 but what you want
to check is is two C times five
doubled 20 C and then that is two C
times five is 10 C doubled is 20 C so
this is - C - 5 the quantity squared you
can use the box method a lot of students
just like to do that just so there's
less to memorize but let's add this to
our our sheet over here it can also be a
perfect square trinomial so if you have
a squared minus 2a B plus B Square
or a squared plus two a B plus B squared
you're going to factor it as a minus B
the quantity squared or a plus B the
quantity squared so that's a perfect
square trinomial and again the nice
thing about factoring is you could write
this 2c minus 5 twice and foil it out
and you'll get back to the original but
again just to refresh what I did is I
took the square root of this first term
and I got to see okay so that's like my
a value I took the square root of the
last term 25 that's my B value and then
I said is a times B times 2 C to a B is
that match the middle term and it did so
that's how I knew was a perfect square
trinomial now if this was plus 20 C I
would make this plus 5 okay let's go to
number eight y cubed plus 125 greatest
common factor doesn't look like it how
many terms it looks like there's two
terms is it a sum of two cubes
difference that you cubes or difference
of two squares or it could be neither
right sometimes you know these are not
factorable at all and then you would
just say you know relatively prime I
mean you can we can't factor it and so
then over here it looks like what we
have is this is a perfect cube because Y
times y times y this is a perfect cube
5 times 5 times 5 so it looks like we
have a sum of two cubes and this problem
our a value is y our B value is 5 and
we're gonna use our sum of two cubes
formula so this is going to be y plus 5
C a plus B a squared minus a B plus B
squared which is 5 squared which is 25
and you've got it leave a comment below
in the comments to let me know and let
others know if you're able to complete
these 100 factoring problems and also
how many you were able to get right so
let's go to number 9 3x squared minus
10x minus 8 so how would you factor that
one well let's see there's three terms
there's not a greatest common factor we
could do the Box method or the AC method
or trial and error method you can see
the leading coefficients and not one
what we're gonna do is we're gonna do
the AC method we're gonna say
see 3 times negative 8 negative 24 what
multiplies to negative 24 but it adds to
the middle coefficient negative 10 well
that's gonna be negative 12x and
positive 2x so what I did is I split the
middle term and then we just bring down
the last term in the first term now you
can see we have one two three four terms
we can do our factoring by grouping so
this is called splitting the middle term
and factoring by grouping so I'm
grouping the first two I'm grouping the
last two and these are added together we
have to factor out the greatest common
factor that's going to be 3x here we can
factor out the greatest common factor
that's going to be two and you can see
we have an X minus 4 in common so if we
factor out that X minus 4 we're gonna be
left with 3x plus 2 and you've got it
now you always want to check to see if
you can factor further in this case we
can't so let's go to number 10 so number
tell we've got four terms we don't have
a greatest common factor so how do you
think you could factor that one well
when four terms we usually think
factoring by grouping so I'm going to
group the first two group the last two
and realize that those are added
together factor out the greatest common
factor which in this case is y squared
so we're left with 5y minus 1 here the
greatest common factor is just going to
be 2 and so you can see we're left with
5y minus 1 and again you can check if
you distribute back in that's 10 y -2
you get back that original polynomial
there and now we have a 5y minus 1 in
common if we factor that 5y minus 1 out
of this group we're left with y squared
if we factor out the 5y minus 1 out of
this group we're left with positive 2
and then you always want to check to see
if you can factor further in this case
we can't so we've got a completely
factored for number 11 doesn't look like
there's a greatest common factor doesn't
look like let's see it looks like we
have two terms so and we can see that
this is a minus so let's see is it a
difference of two squares well let's see
this is actually a perfect square that's
6y and this is a perfect square that's
7z and this is adding this was going to
be Plus this was gonna be minus or vice
versa it doesn't really matter because
this multiplication is commutative so we
factored as a summand
it's pattern because this was a
difference of two squares can we factor
further no so that looks like that's
going to be our final result okay for
number 12 what do you think for this one
is there a greatest common factor yes it
looks like there is looks like we can
factor out of 5
you could divide these both by 5 looks
like this is three A's that's 2a so the
most they have in common is two A's or a
squared 1 B 2 B's looks like the most
number of bees they have in common is 1b
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
factor out that greatest common factor
of 5a squared B if we divide this group
by 5a squared B we're gonna be just left
with a if we divide this group by 5a
squared B we're going to be left with 2
B and again you can check your work if
you distribute back in you get back the
original polynomial here we can't factor
further so that's our final result okay
for number 13 what do you think for this
one y squared minus 8y plus 15 there's
not a greatest common factor right looks
like there's three terms
leaving coefficient is one okay when the
leading coefficients one those ones are
usually pretty easy right all you have
to do is ask yourself what your numbers
multiply to 15 but they have to add to
negative eight well that's going to be
negative five and negative three because
negative five times negative three is
positive 15 negative 5y and negative 3y
this is the middle one negative 8y can
we factor further null so that's fully
factored okay for number fourteen what
do you think for this one well let's see
we've got three terms there's not a
greatest common factor the leading
coefficient is not 1 so that's gonna be
in this form right here we could do the
AC method box method trial and error but
what jumps out I mean here is that this
is a perfect square
3y times 3y this is a perfect square one
times one and if I take 3y times 1
that's 3 y double that's 6y so it's
fitting this e squared to a BB squared
perfect square trinomial pattern so we
can factor this as 3y plus 1 the
quantity squared now if this was minus
6y this would be minus 1 so you see how
I did that
recognizing the first one's a perfect
square the last ones a perfect square
and then you multiply them together and
double it if it matches that
it'll term you know then you know you've
got a perfect square trinomial on your
hands now in order for this to be a
perfect square this last one it has to
be positive right if this is negative
one that's not a perfect square so
that's something to pay attention to so
for number fifteen what do you think for
this one we've got a trinomial leading
coefficients not one looks like we're in
the same boat as this last problem right
but let's see it looks like is this a
perfect square yes because that's a e is
this a perfect square yes because that
seven is eighty times seven doubled 112
e well yeah that's 56 doubled is 112 and
you see this is minus 112 so this is
eighty minus seven the quantity squared
and again if you want to check your work
take eighty minus seven times another 80
minus seven and multiply it out and
you'll see that you get back to the
original polynomial for number 16 what
do you think for this one EQ minus one
well there's not a greatest common
factor there's just two terms right is
it a difference of two squares or is it
a difference of two cubes well it looks
like it's a difference of two cubes
because one cubed is 1 e cubed is eq'd
so you can see that in our formula here
a is going to be e and B is going to be
1 so this is your a value this is your B
value all you have to do now is
substitute in using that same op so
always positive for the signs so this is
going to be e minus 1 so that's the same
C if we subtract we subtract then it's a
squared opposite all right sign so you
subtract you add that's going to be a
times B which is going to be e plus B
squared which is going to be a 1 squared
which is 1 so same opposite always
positive and you've got it now you want
to check and see if you can factor
further in this case we can't so that's
as far as you can go and you've got it
fully factored ok if you're rolling your
eyes and you're like Mario these are too
easy go to the last 20 or 25 or 30
problems in this video and try those
this might be a little bit more
challenging for you but we're going
through the different types in it's
should be getting a little more
difficult as we go through so this one
we've got three terms leading
coefficient is not one there's not a
greatest common factor let's do the EC
method 5 times negative 2 is negative 10
so what two numbers multiply to negative
10 but
add that middle coefficient positive
nine well you can see that's going to be
10 X and negative 1 X add up to the 9x
and and let's see this bring down the
negative two and bring down the 5x
squared and now what we're gonna do is
we're going to factor by grouping so we
want to make sure you capture that sign
these are actually going to be added
together factor out the greatest common
factor that's 5x factor out the negative
one that's the greatest common factor
notice we have an X plus 2 in common if
we factor that out we're going to be
left with 5x minus 1 and you've got it
let's look at number 18 so this one
you've got two terms there's not a
greatest common factor it looks like
it's a difference of two squares because
Y times y is y squared 9 times 9 is 81
ones adding one subtracting you've got
your sum and difference pattern and you
factored it number 19 what do you think
for this one is there a greatest common
factor no it looks like we've got four
terms so we're thinking factoring by
grouping again right so group group and
these are added together factor out the
greatest common factor which is 4a
squared so that gives you a plus 3
factored out the greatest common factor
here which is negative 3 that gives you
a plus 3 I've an A plus 3 in common if
we factor that out we're gonna be left
with 4a squared minus 3 now you want to
look if this was 4a squared minus 9 for
example then that would be a difference
of two squares we would factor it
further but in this case it's not a
difference of two squares we can't
factor it further that's as far as we
can go for number 20 you can see we've
got a trinomial there's not a greatest
common factor the leading coefficients
one these ones generally are pretty easy
for students you just say to yourself
what two numbers multiply to positive 24
but they have to add to the middle
coefficient 10 and that's just going to
be positive 6 and positive 4 you can
check your work by foiling 6 C + 4 C
gives you the 10 C and you know you're
gonna see that you get back to your
original one
number 21 we've got a trinomial this one
it looks like we can factor out a
greatest common factor of 4 they're all
divisible by 4 right and it looks like
they all have at least one C in common
so if we divide out a 4 c out of all
three of these you can see we're going
to have 4 c squared
10 c plus 3 now you want to see if you
can factor it further so if we use that
AC method 4 times 3 what multiplies to
12 but adds to 10 there really isn't
anything so in this case this is as far
as we can go was just a greatest common
factor type of factoring problem for 22
we've got a binomial it does look like
we have a greatest common factor here we
can divide both of these by 7y squared
and if we factor out that 7y squared you
can see here this is gonna reduce to 3
this is going to reduce to Y again if
you distribute that 7y squared back in
you're going to get back to the original
polynomial for 23 you've got a trinomial
leading coefficients 1 these ones are
usually pretty easy there's not a
greatest common factor so we just have
to ask ourselves you know Mario what two
numbers multiply to negative 56
but add to one that's the that's the
question right so there'd be positive 8
and negative 7 D negative 70 gives you
the one D and you've got it 24 you can
see we have a trinomial
now the greatest common factor but the
leading coefficient is not 1 so it's
gonna be like this last one here let's
do the box method on this one so a times
C what multiplies to negative 56 two
numbers that multiply to negative 56 but
those same two numbers have to add to
the middle coefficient which you can see
as a positive one so that looks like
it's going to be positive 8 and negative
7 right so what we can do now if we do
our box method is draw a box this is
going to be 14x squared this is going to
be negative 4 okay and then here we're
going to put in 8x and negative 7x
greatest common factor for this row is
going to be 2x so that's going to give
us 7 X plus 4 greatest common factor for
this row is going to be negative 1 and
you can double-check 7x times negative 1
is negative 7x 4 times negative 1 is
negative 4 so our fully factored form
here is going to be 2x minus 1 times 7x
plus 4 and you got it okay number 25
we've got one two three four terms
there's not a greatest common factor so
let's try our factoring by grouping so
we want to group the first two terms
group the last two terms these aren't
multiplied together they're actually
together we factor out the greatest
common factor which in this case is d
squared here the greatest common factor
is a negative 5 you can see we have a 7
d plus 2 in common if we factor out that
7t + 2 we're going to be left with d
squared minus 5 now if this had been d
squared minus 4 that's a difference of
two squares and we can factor it further
but in this case that's as far as we can
go for 26 we've got 64 minus F cubed you
can see there's not a greatest common
factor it looks like it's a difference
of 2 cubed 2 qs 64 is 4 cubed and of
course this is f cubed so in our formula
for the difference of two cubes a is
going to be 4 and B is going to be F so
if we factor this is going to be same
and if you subtract we subtract a
squared is get 4 squared which is 16 the
opposite that's 4 times F which is 4 F
plus B squared B is f so this is going
to be f squared and that's as far as we
can factor it for 27 we've got two terms
it looks like a difference of two
squares so we're going to factor it
using that sum and difference pattern a
plus one a minus one or you could do a
minus 1 a plus 1 and you've got at
number 28 we've got a trinomial this
one's pretty easy because the leading
coefficients of one we just have to
factor it asking ourselves what two
numbers multiply to 48 but add to 19 and
that's going to be 16 and 3 and you've
got it for 29 it looks like we've got a
greatest common factor of 3 acts so
let's factor out that 3 acts this is
going to be x squared plus 4x plus 6 is
there something that multiplies to 6 two
numbers and multiply to 6 but add to 4
no so that's as far as we can go in that
one just factor out the greatest common
factor for number 30 we have a sum of
two cubes because 216 is actually like
six cubes 6 times 6 times 6 G cubed is G
times G times G so here we have a sum of
two cubes we're going to use this soap
formula here the sum of two cubes
formula so g plus 6 g squared minus 6 g
plus 6 squared which is 36 so same
opposite always positive that's our soap
acronym to remember the signs 431 we've
got a trinomial
there's no greatest common factor
leading coefficients not 1 okay so we
can either do the box method the AC
method let's do the AC method what
multiplies to negative 60 but adds to
this middle coefficient which is
negative 7 well it looks like that's
going to be 12 negative 12 X and
positive 5 X so the negative 12 times 5
is negative 60 negative 12 plus 5 is
negative 7 so this is just called like
splitting the middle term bring down the
last term bring down the first term now
we've got four terms we can do our
factoring by grouping so we grouped the
first to group the last to realize these
are added together and then factor out
that greatest common factor this is
going to be X minus 3 here we can factor
out the greatest common factor which is
5 that's X minus 3 we've got an X minus
3 in common
we can factor the X minus 3 out and
we're left with 4x plus 5
okay 432 we've got a trinomial there's
not a greatest common factor the leading
coefficients not one we could use the
box method or the AC method but what
jumps out at me here is that this first
term is a perfect square
see 4m times for M this last term is a
perfect square 3 times 3 and then if we
do for M times 3 is 12 m double this 24
m so it's fitting this perfect square
trinomial pattern so this is 4 M plus 3
square not cubes squared and if this was
a minus 24 M then this would be a minus
3 so this is a binomial squared so
remember there's a worksheet a free
worksheet in the description below if
you want to get then print it out to
practice but let's continue on it's a 33
which what I look for is the greatest
counter factor which there isn't one
notice the leading coefficient is not 1
so what I like to do when the leading
coefficient is not 1 is check to see if
this is a perfect square which it is
it's 10 L check to see if the last term
is a perfect square which it is it's 9 M
then you just have to see is 10 L times
9 m doubled 180 LM well it is this is 90
LM doubled is 180 LM because this is -
this is going to be minus and it's the
quantity squared if this is Plus this
would be possible
perfect square trinomial pattern over
here that we talked about earlier let's
look at number 34 we've got four terms
there's not a greatest common factor
we're gonna factor by grouping factor
out the greatest common factor which is
going to be X cubed okay so that's going
to be X minus four factor out the
greatest common factor here greatest
common factors - that's X minus four we
have an X minus four in common if we
factor that out we're left with x cubed
plus two now if this was X cubed plus
one there'd be a sum of two cubes we
could factor that further but in this
case that's as far as we can go for 35
looks like we have a difference of two
squares these are probably getting
pretty easy for you now that's gonna be
D plus 11 D minus eleven because 11
squared is 121 this one's also a
difference of two squares this is four Y
squared plus one and four Y squared
minus one right because four Y squared
times four Y squared that's 16 Y to the
fourth but this is you can factor
further this is actually going to be 2y
plus 1 and 2 y minus 1 that's a
difference of two squares this is a sum
of two squares which we really can't
factor over this set of real numbers you
can do it over the set of imaginary
numbers or complex numbers so we're just
going to leave that in its current form
and you've got it for number 37 you
always look for that greatest common
factor it looks like we can factor out a
2 P so that's going to be PQ minus 8
this is a difference of two cubes
because remember 8 is 2 times 2 times 2
and this is P cubed so in this case on
our formula a is going to be P and B is
going to be 2 so this is going to be P
minus 2 P squared plus 2 P plus 2
squared which is 4 and that's fully
factored so notice how we're like having
to factor a little bit more now that
we're getting further on in this
worksheet here first we did the greatest
common factor then we had this
difference of two cubes you could even
have something after that you might have
to factor 2 3 4 times for number 38 it
doesn't look like there's a greatest
common factor we can group it and do the
factoring by grouping so if we factor
out an x squared factor
negative one we can see we have an X
plus two in common if we factor that out
of this group we're left with x squared
if we factor out of this group we're
left with negative one this is a
difference of two squares so we can
factor it as X plus one X minus one and
then just bring down the X plus two so
see how it's getting a little bit more
multi-step now for number thirty-nine
you want to look for the greatest common
factor it looks like we can divide all
these by two
looks like they all have at least one X
looks like they all have at most one Y
so we're gonna divide out a 2x Y out of
all these terms that's gonna be our
greatest common factor and here we're
going to be left with Y here we're going
to be left with 2x and here we're gonna
be left with 4 X Y and you've got it and
this can't be factored further so that's
as far as we can go for number 40 the
leading coefficient is 1 it's a
trinomial there's not a greatest counter
factor these ones like we said are
getting not probably pretty easy for you
what multiplies to negative 36 but adds
to negative 5 that's going to be
negative 9 and positive 4 and it's fully
factored okay number 41 we've got 6 C
squared minus CD minus 2 d squared it's
a trinomial the leading coefficients not
one let's do the ICI methods let's just
look at the coefficients six times
negative 2 what multiplies to negative
12 but adds that middle coefficient
negative 1 well that's going to be
negative 4 and positive 3 so negative 4
cd plus positive 3 CD is the negative 1
CD let's bring down the negative 2 d
squared and the 6 C squared and let's
factor by grouping so if we factor out
the greatest common factor here which is
to see we're left with 3 C minus 4 D
actually 3 C minus 2 D and here if we
factor out the greatest common factor
out of these last two terms which would
be just D we have 3 C minus 2 d notice
how we have a 3 C minus 2 D in common we
can factor out that 3 C minus 2 D and
we're left with 2 C plus 1 D and that's
fully factored
okay that was a tougher one because we
had two variables C and D okay number 42
we've got a trinomial it looks like you
can factor out a three out of all these
terms so that's going to be 4x squared
plus 12x plus 9 notice that this is a
perfect square that's 2x times 2x so
this is a perfect square that's 3 times
3 2x times 3 is 6x doubled is 12x so
that's a perfect square trinomial
patterns so a binomial squared and we
bring down that greatest common factor
the 3 and that's a fully factored number
43 it looks like we can factor out a 7
out of both of these and one deatta both
of these so if we factor out the 7 d
we're gonna be left with 7 C squared
minus let's see what would this be this
would be 3 d cubed we can't factor this
any further so that's as far as we can
go and it looks like this is actually C
cubed C cubed because we just factored
out a D so the DS cancelled we had C
cubed and - 3 D cubed yeah there you go
okay for number 44 this one's pretty
easy you can see the leading
coefficients 1 it's a trinomial there's
not a greatest common factor what
multiplies to negative 3 but adds to
positive 2 that's going to be 3 and
negative 1 so L plus 3 times L minus 1
for 45 we have a trinomial the leading
coefficient is not 1 it looks like we
can factor out a 3 here so let's do that
that's always going to make it easier if
the numbers are smaller right
multiply the a and the C together what
multiplies to negative 6 but adds to
negative 1 well that's going to be
negative 3 and positive 2 and if we
bring down the last term and bring down
the first term now what we can do is
factor by grouping okay and it looks
like the greatest common factor here is
3x that's 2x minus 1 here we can only
factor out like a 1 so that's 2x minus 1
so you can see this is going to be 2x
minus 1 times 3x plus 1 and if we bring
that greatest common factor out from the
initial step the 3 that's gonna be fully
factored if you want to check your work
you can multiply all this out and
double-check for in 46 you can factor
out a greatest counter factor of 3 y
squared so that's going
give us 27y cubed minus one this is a
difference of two Q's because 27y cubed
that's like 3y cubed and one cubed of
course is perfect cubed and so it's the
difference in two cubes this is like our
a value this is like our B value in our
difference of two cubes formula so this
is 3y squared 3 y -1 3 Y the quantity
squared which is 9 Y squared plus 3y
plus negative sorry plus 1 squared which
is 1 so that's going to be fully
factored so start with the greatest
common factor that makes everything a
little bit smaller then see if you can
factor it further from there and keep on
going so for 47 it looks like we can
factor out a 5 so that's going to be 25
y squared minus 9 this is a difference
of two squares so we can factor it as 5
y + 3 + 5 y minus 3 and we just have to
bring down that 5 and that's fully
factored and then for 48 looks like we
can factor out a 5 y out of all of these
terms so that's going to be 5y 16 - 8 y
plus y squared and then if you notice
that this is a perfect square
4 times 4 this is a perfect square
because Y times y and let's see 4 times
y is 4 y doubled is 8y so this is 4
minus y squared that's a perfect square
trinomial bring down that greatest
common factor 5 Y and you've got it
fully factored okay number 49 we've got
36 y squared minus 120 X y plus 100 x
squared remember the first step is
always that greatest common factor it
looks like we can divide out a 4 so
let's do that first we've got 9y squared
minus 30x y plus 25 x squared now we've
got a trinomial the leading coefficients
not 1 but notice how this is a perfect
square this is also a perfect square we
have a perfect square trinomial on our
hands possibly let's double check square
root of 9 y squared is 3 y square root
of 25 x squared is 5 X is 3 y times 5 X
thirty XY yes because this is 15 XY
doubled is 30 X Y so this is going to be
three y minus five X the quantity
squared we just have to bring down that
for the we factored out initially and we
got it completely factored okay number
50 were halfway five X to the fourth
minus 320 X first step remember is to
factor out that greatest common factor
which in this case looks like five acts
so that's going to be X cubed minus 64
but notice we have a binomial and it's
actually a difference of two cubes
because 64 is 4 cubed and of course X
cubed is perfect cube so we've got X
minus 4 x squared plus 4 X plus 4
squared which is 16 and we just bring
down that 5x so I'm just using this
difference of two cubes formula the same
apps and always positive 451 you can see
we've got four terms here we're thinking
factoring by grouping right so here I'm
going to group these first two terms
together group the last two terms and
these are added together so if we factor
out the greatest common factor Y cubed
we have Y plus 1 here if we factor out
the greatest common factor which is 8 we
have y plus 1 notice how we have a y
plus 1 in common we can then factor that
y plus 1 out and we're left with y cubed
plus 8 now when you look at Y cubed plus
8 you can see this is actually what it's
a sum of two cubes because 8 is 2 cubed
so it can really factor this further
into y plus 2 y squared minus 2 y plus 2
squared which is 4 so our final factored
form I'm just going to cross out the Y
cubed plus 8 it equals all of this times
the y plus 1 and that's fully factored
ok now 52 it looks like we've got four
terms but there's a greatest common
factor of two a so let's factor out that
2a that's going to give us a cubed plus
3 a squared 3 a squared minus minus 4 a
minus 12 ok now we have four terms we're
thinking factoring by grouping so if I
take out the greatest common factor here
we're going to have
a squared which gives us a plus three if
they take out the greatest common factor
out of these two that's going to be
negative four which gives us a plus
three and see I have that a plus three
in common you can factor that out when
we factor that out that's going to leave
us with a squared minus four but that's
a difference of two squares so we can
factor it as a plus to a minus two and
remember don't forget about that
greatest common factor the 2a we've
factored out initially you want to bring
that down in front okay number 53 we've
got a trinomial it looks like there's a
greatest common factor of a two here so
let's factor that out first four I
squared plus 7y minus two leading
coefficients not one this is a perfect
square but two is not a perfect square
so we don't have a perfect square
trinomial on our hands but we can do our
AC method we could say 4 times negative
2 is negative 8 so what multiplies to
negative 8 but adds to positive 7 well
that's gonna be a y so we're just gonna
be 8 and negative 1 but we can split
this up into 8 Y and negative 1 Y which
adds up to the 7 Y so I'm just splitting
the middle term and factoring by
grouping now so if we factor out the
greatest common factor out of these 2
and the greatest common factor out of
these two we get let's see for Y that's
y plus 2 and if i factor out a negative
1 we get y plus 2 and so now let's see
I'm running out of space we've got y
plus 2 in common if we factor that out
we're gonna have y plus 2 for y -1 and
we just have to put that 2 in front that
was our initial greatest common factor
so you can see this are getting to be a
little bit more multi-step let's look at
number 54 so 54 it looks like we have a
greatest common factor of what looks
like 4 so we factor out a 4 we get MN
squared minus 6 M plus 5 and cubed now
actually this would be a 2 right here
because 4 times 2 is 8 MN squared okay
and you can always double check by
distributing back in when I look at this
here this can't be factored any further
so that's as far as we can go in this
case it was just the greatest common
factor of 4 that we could pull out so
455 it looks like we can factor out a
greatest common factor again looks like
it's actually going to be
24a so if we divide these both by 24 a
we get 9 a squared minus 1 this is a
difference of two squares we can factor
that as 3 a plus 1 and 3 a minus 1 and
we just have to bring down that 24 a ok
456 we've got a trinomial there's not a
greatest common factor the leading
coefficients 1 so these tend to be a
little bit easier we just have to say
what multiplies to positive 56 but adds
to negative 18 that's going to be
negative 14 and negative 4 you can
double check by foiling that out you'll
get back to original polynomial okay
number 57 we have e squared plus 12y
minus 45 this one's pretty
straightforward it's a trinomial leading
coefficients one all we have to do is
say what two numbers multiply to
negative 45 but add to 12 and you can
see that that's going to be let's see 15
and negative 3 for number 58 we've got a
trinomial but it looks like we have a
greatest common factor of let's see it
looks like they all have an R in common
at least one R in common then it looks
like they all have at least one s in
common so we can do is we can divide all
these terms by RS or factor out the RS
and you can see we're gonna be left with
4 R squared plus 2 s plus 3 r s and we
really can't factor that any further so
you got it
number 59 it looks like we have a
trinomial looks like we have a greatest
common factor of 2 a so if you factor
that out we have 3a squared minus 5a
minus 12
but what two numbers multiply to
negative 36 and add to negative 5 that's
going to be negative 9
and positive for so we can split that
middle term into negative 98 and
positive for a you can do the box method
on this one if you prefer and so now all
we have to do is we have four terms so
let's see if we can do the factoring by
grouping let's factor out a three out of
these first two terms that's going to
give us a minus three let's factor out a
four out of these last two terms notice
how we have an a minus three in common
we can factor that a minus three out and
that's going to leave us with three a
plus four but remember that two a we
factored out initially that goes out in
front of the two factors there for
number 60 it looks like we have a
greatest common factor of ten see cube
so if we factor that out we're gonna be
left with C cubed plus 1000 a thousand
is actually 10 cubed so we have a sum of
two cubes so if we factor this we're
gonna get C plus ten C squared minus ten
C plus 10 squared which is a hundred and
then we just bring down that greatest
common factor
let's look go to number 61 here it looks
like the only thing we can do is factor
out an X that's our greatest common
factor so that's 21 x squared plus 11x
minus 2 trinomial leading coefficients
not one so we can do our AC method okay
and we can say what multiplies to 21
times negative 2 which is negative 42
but has to add to that middle term which
is positive 11 so that's going to be 14
and negative 3 so I'm gonna split that
middle term into 14x and negative 3x
bring down the first and last term's
and now what we're gonna do is we're
going to factor by grouping since we
have four terms if i factor out a
greatest common factor and factor out a
negative one out of the last two terms
see how we have a 3x plus 2 in common we
can factor that out and we're going to
be left with 7x minus 1 but don't forget
about the ax we factor out initially so
you can see there's a lot of steps you
know as you go on but it starts with the
greatest common factor and then you
analyze how many terms to three or four
terms 462 what do you think for this one
one minus 343 M cubed we're getting into
some larger numbers also so it really
helps to know your perfect squares and
perfect
cubes 343 is actually seven cubes so
this is actually going to be a
difference of two cubes it's going to be
1 minus 7m + 1 + 7 M + 7 m to quantity
square which is 49 m squared same
opposite always positive and we can't
factor it any further from there for 63
we've got four terms this is going to be
our typical factoring by grouping if we
factor out the greatest common factor
here we can only factor out a 1 but
notice how we have a C squared minus 4
in common we can factor out that C
squared minus 4 we're left with C cubed
plus 1 but notice we have a difference
of two squares and a sum of two cubes so
some more faster we need to do here this
is going to factor out to C plus 2 and C
minus 2 this one sum of two cubes is
going to factor to C plus 1 C squared
minus C plus 1 squared which is just 1
so that one was kind of involved a lot
of different types of factoring for 64
looks like we have a difference of two
squares okay because if you think about
this this is actually like 8 C cubed
times 8 C cubed right and then 729 is
actually a a perfect square that's 27
times 27 but remember when you factor a
difference of two squares it's a sum and
difference pattern a plus B a minus B
right but now look what we have this is
actually a perfect cube it's to see the
quantity cubed 27 is 3 cubed same thing
here this is a perfect cube minus a
perfect cube so we have a sum of two
cubes in a difference of two cubes back
to our soap formula this is going to
factor to 2c plus three times to see the
quantity squared which is 4 C squared
minus 6 C plus 9 and then this is going
to factor to 2c minus 3 to see the
quantity squared which is 4 C squared
plus 6 C plus 3 squared which is 9 so
this one was actually a combination of a
sum of two cubes and a difference of two
cubes as well as a difference of
you squares initially okay number 65 it
looks like we can factor out a greatest
common factor here it looks like they're
both terms are divisible by five looks
like they both have two x's in common x
squared I mean it looks like they both
have two Y's in common like Y squared so
if we divide out that five x squared Y
squared as a greatest common factor
we're gonna be left with Y squared minus
four X and we can't factor this any
further it's not a difference of two
squares so it looks like with just the
greatest common factor on that one for
number 66 we've got a trinomial the
leading coefficient is 1 so these are
the ones that we've been talking about
as being pretty easy you just have to
say what multiplies to 64 but adds to
negative 20 that's gonna be let's see
negative 16 and negative 4 and you got
it
see for this one we've got a difference
of two squares so this is going to be
one plus three Y and 1 minus three Y so
I almost pretty straightforward
number 68 it looks like see how these
all and in 0 that means we can factor
out a 10 so that's going to be 4 d
squared plus 28 D plus 49 but it looks
like this is a perfect square this is a
perfect square let's see if we have a
perfect square trinomial here we've got
2 D times 7 which is 14 D doubled is 28
D so this is a perfect square and we
just bring down that greatest common
factor okay for number 69 let's see
we've got four terms so we're thinking
factoring by grouping right so group the
first two group the last two those are
added together factor out the GCF out of
both groups looks like we have an e
minus 2 in common that we can factor out
so e minus 2 and we're left with the
cube plus 2 this is not a sum of two Q's
we can't take that any further
so we're gonna leave it just like that
number 70 it looks like there's not a
greatest common factor that starts with
a negative which is a little bit messy
so why don't we factor out that negative
first so that's going to flip the signs
now notice how we have a perfect square
here right so this is actually 3a times
3a
this is a perfect square
B times 5b 3 8 times 5 B is 15 a B
double is 38 B so it looks like we have
a perfect square trinomial and we just
bring down that greatest common factor
we factor out initially that negative
number 71 again this is an easy one
because the leading coefficient is 1
it's a trinomial we just have to figure
out what multiplies to 24 but adds to
negative 10 that's going to be negative
6 and negative 4 number 72 we've got a
trinomial leading coefficient is not 1
there's not a greatest common factor
let's do the box method on this one so
what multiplies to negative 30 but adds
to negative 13 okay so let's see what
would that be multiplies to negative 30
but it adds to negative 13 so that would
be negative 15 and positive 2 right so
negative 15 and positive 2 and I'm just
going to add the X in there see how
these add up to the negative 13x put the
negative 3 here and the 10x squared here
now all we have to do is factor out the
greatest common factor out of this role
which is 2x that leaves us with 5x plus
1 and here a factor out the greatest
common factor out of this row which is
negative 3 double check that gives us
negative 15 X that gives us negative 3
so our two factors are going to be 5x
plus 1 that's this group and 2x minus 3
and if you foil that out you're going to
get back the original polynomial okay
number 73
now this one's kind of an interesting
one things are getting a little crazy
now here we've actually got six terms
but if you look at it closely what
you'll notice is we can factor this
these first three terms we could also
factor these last three terms so let's
start there here you can see that this
is actually a perfect square trinomial
this is going to be X minus 1 squared
here what I'm gonna do is going to
factor out a negative 1 out of all three
of these terms so that's going to be Y
squared plus 6y plus 9 notice this is
also a perfect square trinomial
that's y plus 3 squared now notice what
we have we have a difference of two
squares okay so this is actually going
to be X minus 1 okay plus y plus 3
and X minus one minus y plus three so
you could leave it like that or we could
simplify it down a little bit more let's
see if we can simplify it just a little
bit more this is going to be X plus y
plus two this is going to be X minus y
minus four and that's as far as we can
go on that one
so here we had to kind of do it in two
groups first okay number 74 we've got X
to the sixth minus 7x cubed minus eight
now one thing I want to point out to you
here is see how this leading I'm sorry
see how this middle term see the X cubed
see how that power is half of that
leading terms power this is what's
called in quadratic form okay so you
would know how to factor this if this
was x squared minus 7x minus eight right
what would you say you would say well
this is like X what multiplies to
negative eight but ATS negative seven
you would say that's minus eight and
positive one but the only thing we do
now is make these cubed okay because X
cubed times X cubed gives us X to the
sixth and negative 8x cubed and positive
1x cubed adds up to the negative 7x
cubed so it's just like factoring
quadratics but we're going to take it
one step further because we have a sum
of two cubes in a difference of two
cubes 8 is 2 cubed so let's factor this
a little bit more X minus 2 x squared
plus 2 X plus 2 squared which is 4 and
here we have X plus 1 times x squared
minus whoops x squared minus X plus 1
squared which is 1 so it's all of that
multiplied together
ok let's go to number 75 this one's an
easy one so just kind of break up some
of the tough ones here to give us a
little a little rest here so what
multiplies to negative 56 adds up to
negative one that's going to be negative
8 and positive 7 for number 76 we've got
some larger numbers here we could do the
AC method 12 times negative 14 that's a
pretty big number and we'd have to
figure out what adds to negative 13 two
numbers that multiply to what do we say
negative 168 but adds to negative 13 so
what I'm going to do here on this one is
I'm actually going to just do a little
bit of a trial and error method so what
two numbers multiply to 12 y squared
that could either be 4y + 3 y 6
- I twelve Y and one y let's start with
4 y + 3 y then we're gonna jump to the
last term's what multiplies to negative
14 but we want the inner product the
outer product to add up to negative 13y
so let's see I'm thinking 7 + 2 this is
going to give us 8 y 21 Y we want this
to be negative 21 Y and positive 8y that
adds up to the negative 13y we've got it
so I use the trial and error method on
that one you could do the AC method the
box method etc let's do number 77 this
one we've got a difference of two
squares this is actually a perfect
square it's 16 X to the eighth times 16
X to the eighth plus one minus one right
so it's a difference of two squares but
see the 68 minus one this is actually a
difference of two squares that's 4 X to
the fourth plus 1 + 4 X to the fourth
minus 1 okay let's bring this down and
then this one is also a difference of
two squares we can factor this into 2x
whoops my reading is getting a little
messy here so 2x squared + 1 + 2 x
squared - 1 and let's bring these two
terms down just for X to the 4th plus 1
we can't factor that it's a sum of two
squares same thing with this one you
could factor it over the set of complex
numbers we're just working with real
numbers right now so that would be your
fully factored form
ok 478 this is a little bit easier this
is a perfect square and this is a
perfect square let's see if we have a
perfect square trinomial on our hands
here we've got 4 squared which is 16 3
the quantity squared is 90 squared 4
times 3 is 12 you doubled is 24 e so
this is just a perfect square 4 - 3 e
the quantity square ok fraction so we're
trying to take it up a notch as we get
further along in this worksheet we want
to factor out that fraction okay to make
this a little bit easier looking at the
denominators 3 + 27 27 s our least
common multiple so let's factor out a
127th ok so when you factor out 127th on
the inside here it's like multiplying by
the reciprocal 27 over 127 over 1 times
1
it actually gives us 9 and 27 over 1
times 1 27th gives us 1 you can double
check if you distribute you're gonna get
back to the original but notice now we
have a difference of two squares we can
factor that as 3 y + 1 3 y -1 we just
have to bring down that 127th in front
okay and that's it so let's look at
number 80
so number 80 we've got a difference of
two squares X plus 1 is a squared and 36
is 6 squared so let's write this as X
plus 1 plus 6 and X plus 1 minus 6 we
can combine like terms here so let's
write this as X plus 7 and X minus 5
that's your final factored form okay
number 81 we've got quite a expression
here but it looks like the first step
you know is always the greatest common
factor let's see what we can divide out
of both of these groups see how the
groups are separated by - looks like we
can factor out a 3 it looks like this
has one X plus one this has two X plus
one so that we can only factor out one
out of each and it looks like this has X
minus 2 one of them this has X minus two
three of them so we can only factor out
one that they have in common okay so
this is our greatest common factor it's
gonna be three X plus one X minus two
and then when we do that these are gonna
cancel these are going to cancel and one
of these is going to cancel leaving us
with X minus two squared this is going
to be minus three this is going to be X
plus one and these are gonna cancel
let's see if we can expand this because
you know it might be that it can be
factored further let's double check so x
squared minus four X plus four minus
three X minus three if we combine like
terms we get x squared minus seven X
plus one that doesn't look like it can
be factored so that's as far as we can
go with that one and then we've got
three X plus one X minus two okay so
that was a big one but it basically was
just a greatest common factor problem
for number 82 this was pretty easy you
can see that leading coefficients one
this is a perfect square and this is a
perfect square so let's see if this is a
perfect square trinomial C times ten is
ten C doubled is 20 CC
this is a perfect square trinomial
number 83 we have a trinomial with a
leading coefficient that's not one
so we'll do our EC method what
multiplies to negative 42 but adds to
positive 19 that looks like that's going
to be 21 and negative 2 so I'm splitting
that metal term up into 21 see a
negative 2 see now we can factor by
grouping so if i factor out a 7 C we get
to C plus 3 if i factor out a negative 1
we get to C plus 3 if we factor out the
2 C plus 3 we're left with 7 C and this
is like a negative 1 7 C minus 1 okay
for number 84 we've got more fractions
again so let's see so this one 1/4 let's
just factor out the 1/4 that's gonna be
y squared minus 16 because when you
divide out like a like so you're
dividing out 1/4 on the inside it's like
multiply by the reciprocal which is like
multiplying by 4 so that's how we get
the 16 here this is a difference of two
squares y + 4 y - 4 and then we can
bring down the 1/4 okay let's go to
number 85 this one is kind of
interesting it's a difference of two
cubes so we're gonna use our our
difference in cheek use formulas soap so
it's going to be x + 2 y -1 right and
then it's going to be x + 2 y squared
let's see this is going to be + x + 2 y
times 1 and then plus 1 squared which is
just 1 let's see if we can simplify this
a little bit further x + 2 y squared is
x squared + 4 XY + 4 y squared or Y
squared + X + 2 y plus 1 can we combine
the like terms here no it doesn't look
like it so that's we just expanded that
out and this is x + 2 y -1 and that's as
far as we can go on that one okay for
number 86 we've got four terms so let's
just do the factoring by grouping method
so we'll factor out a 2x squared that
leaves us with X plus 3 here we can
factor out a negative
one that leaves us with X plus three you
have an X plus 3 in common we can factor
that X plus 3 out and we're left with
two x squared minus one
you know we really can't factor this
this is not a perfect square so it's not
a difference of two squares for 87 this
one's pretty easy we just have to say
what your numbers multiply to 50 but add
to 27 that's going to be 25 + 2 + 4 88
this one it looks like this is a perfect
square that's 3d times 3d this is a
perfect square that's 5 times 5 is 3d
times 5 doubled 30 D yes so this is a
perfect square trinomial okay number 89
we've got 16 C squared minus the a plus
2 the quantity squared so we have a
difference of two squares so this is
actually going to be 4 C plus a plus 2 +
4 C minus a plus 2 let's simplify it
down a little bit more 4 C plus a plus 2
this is going to be 4 C minus a minus 2
if you distribute that negative so
difference of two squares number 90
let's see we've got a trinomial there's
not a greatest common factor if we do
our AC method what multiplies to
negative 72 that adds to negative 1
that's going to be negative 9 and
positive 8 so I'm just gonna split that
middle term and then what we review is
we're gonna factor by grouping so if i
factor out let's see a negative 3 X
that's going to be X plus 3 and if i
factor out a 4 here that's going to be
let's see do I make a mistake here if we
factor out negative 3 this is going to
be 2 X if we factor out a 4 here this is
going to be 2 X plus 3 so we have a 2 X
plus 3 in common if we factor the 2 X
plus 3 out we have a negative 3 X + 4
now there's another way to do this
problem in the sense that you could
factor out like a negative 1 first and
then factor it further but I just chose
to just divert it in and factor it like
that number 91 we've got some more
fractions okay so how are we gonna
factor this one well it looks like we've
got 8 2 & 2 fur denominators the lowest
common multiple that would be 8 so let's
factor out a 1/8 again remember if you
factor out 1/8 it's like multiplying
inside the
seized by the reciprocal which is eight
over one so this is gonna make this e
squared minus 4a minus twelve and then
we can factor this as a minus six and a
plus two and then just bring down the
one eighth
okay so that was number 91 let's go to
number 92 this one's pretty
straightforward cuz it's a trinomial
leading coefficients one so we just have
to say what multiplies to twenty-three
but adds to negative 24 that's going to
be 24 and negative one actually that's
not true is it right this would be what
am I doing here
let's to go back a step negative 20 30
and negative one there we go cuz a
negative 23 times negative 1 is positive
23 and a of 23 acts and negative 1 X is
negative 24 X okay we're getting tired
here near the end okay number 93 4/9 e
squared minus 4/3 C plus 1 what can we
do on this one well let's see if we can
factor out one nice see if we look at
these fractions here they all have a
denominator that has a lowest common
multiple of 9 so if we factor it all out
of 1/9 we get 4 C squared minus remember
we factor out one ninth it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal in the
parentheses that's like melting by 9
over 1 so this would be 12 C plus 9 okay
so notice that this is a perfect square
to C times to see this is a perfect
square of 3 times 3 2 C times 3 6 C
double is 12 C so this is a perfect
square trinomial and then just bring
down that greatest common factor one
night for 94 it looks like we have a
perfect square trinomial because this is
actually 4w the quantity squared 49 is 7
squared 4w times 7 is 28 w double this
negative 56 w right so 4w minus 7 a
quantity squared for 94 ok we're on to
the last 6 problems here so number 95 we
got 10 X to the 4th plus x squared minus
3 this is in what they call quadratic
form to see how the x squared this 2 is
half of 4 so you would factor it just
like you would factor a normal quadratic
trinomial with a leading coefficient so
here what we're gonna do is we're gonna
say what multiplies to negative 30 but
adds
two positive one and you can see that's
going to be six and negative five so I'm
splitting that middle term into six x
squared and negative five x squared is
bringing down the first and last term's
now I have to do is factor by grouping
so I pull out the greatest common factor
here which is two x squared we get what
five x squared plus three and here if i
factor out a negative one out of these
two terms we also get a five x squared
plus three so if you factor out that
five x squared plus three we're left
with two x squared minus one and it
can't be faster than any further
number 96 this one's a little bit easier
one because leading coefficients one we
just have to say what multiplies to
negative 42 but adds to eleven that's
going to going to be what positive 14
and negative three 497 this one you've
got a leading coefficient negative nine
so let's factor out a negative one
that's gonna flip the signs and then
here what you might notice is that these
are perfect squares this is going to be
three F times three F is nine F squared
four times four is 16 3 F times four is
twelve F double does 24 F and then
that's a perfect square trinomial just
bring down the negative one and you got
it
number 98 you can see we've got four
terms we're thinking factoring by
grouping here you can factor out a 5 Z
cubed which is gonna give you one minus
Z here you can just factor out a
negative one which gives you three minus
Z notice how one minus Z and three minus
Z are not the same that means this point
actually cannot be factored and we're
gonna say this is prime and I think this
is the only prime one the one that
couldn't be factored on this worksheet
number 99 we've got a trinomial leading
coefficient is not 1 so let's do the AC
method what multiplies to negative 200
but adds to that middle term 17 well
that looks like that's going to be 25
and negative 8 so I'm just gonna split
that middle term up into 25 X and
negative 8x bring down the first and
last terms now we're back to factoring
by grouping so if i factor out
five X and here if i factor out a
negative two negative four actually
negative four you want to go for the
greatest common factor so that's 2x plus
five you can see we have a 2x plus five
in common if we factor out the 2x plus
five we're left with 5x minus four and
that's it for that one in the final
problem we've got a trinomial leading
coefficient and not one we're gonna do
our AC method what multiplies to
negative 24 but adds to negative 10 that
is going to be negative 12 Z and
positive 2 Z and so now all we have to
do is do our factoring by grouping let's
factor out a 4 Z let's hear this factor
out a 1 out of those last two terms you
can see we have a 2 Z minus 3 in common
if we factor that out we're left with 4
Z plus 1 and that's our final result so
I hope your skills with factoring really
improved for this video let me know in
the comments below how many you got
right and what you learn from this video
again my channel is all about helping
you to raise your grade pass your class
and go on to pursue your dreams go ahead
and subscribe to the channel and I look
forward to helping you in my other
videos I'll talk to you soon